hi everyone my name is anna williams and
i
am an accreditation supervisor here at
hboi just a little bit about me
i'm the primary point of contact at ety
for our cannabis program so
laboratories testing any form of
marijuana or hemp i'm their primary
point of contact
as well as i'm doing all the outreach
work with additional laboratories and i
get in our system
just a little bit about hvala it stands
for the american association for
laboratory accreditation
so we do accredit laboratories and
organizations to all different kinds of
icing standards so proficiency testing
providers reference material producers
product certifiers things of that nature
we're all over the spectrum
and we currently credit more cannabis
testing laboratories than any other
accreditation body globally
so i have a lot of experience with this
and
hopefully i can get you guys some good
information today today i'm going to be
talking to you guys about the current
regulatory landscape um
updates pending legislative measures and
testing regulation changes that we
should see
throughout 2020 uh the goal will be that
you leave this presentation with a
better understanding of changes
predicted for 2020
as well as an understanding of the
changing regulatory landscape
so i thought to get started i would just
show a map
of just to provide an overview of where
a country currently stands
in terms of legalization and
decriminalization and things of that
nature
so cannabis does for those of you who
aren't as familiar cannabis does
cover both hemp and marijuana as those
two separate categories but a lot of
people are moving away from the term
marijuana because of the
association people have with it so the
purposes of this presentation
anytime i say the word cannabis i am
referring to high thc cannabis
so looking at this map you can see that
currently 11 states have
legalized cannabis for recreational use
if you include washington dc in that mix
that is 12
states and jurisdictions that have
legalized cannabis for recreational
adult use
on the flip side looking at this map you
can see that eight states have not moved
forward with any measures at all to
decriminalize cannabis
concern amounts or even legalize medical
use eleven total states have not yet
legalized cannabis
preventative use at all
so looking at this map this on the flip
side you can see the united states
is a lot more friendly towards hemp
cultivation in
states uh offering up sales so
only three states you can tell idaho
south dakota
and mississippi do not allow for any
help to be cultivated there
washington dc in the united states
territories you can also see they don't
allow hemp to be grown in their state
um some of these states that are
highlighted in dark purple
they do allow for hemp to be around
their state with their own
plan that's been approved by the usda
where some states do not yet have
anything in place yet requiring testing
i'll talk a little bit more about the
usda and their interim rule in
specifically regards to testing on
another slide
so on the horizon so i'm going to be
like i said
talking to you guys about legalization
measures um states pending further
legalization as well as states pushing
additional testing requirements or any
testing requirements later in 2020
i'm also going to be talking to you guys
about testing regulations on a federal
level
giving at least a brief overview of what
the usda is looking for
in terms of figuring out what they want
to do for testing laboratories
obviously 2020 is an election year so a
lot of states and advocacy groups are
working to get cannabis legalization
measures
on their state's ballot and they're
hoping that residents can vote for
legalizing canvas in their state
even if their legislator isn't
necessarily as friendly towards
it so i'm first going to go through each
state's status and legalization measures
for 2020.
i'm also going to review whether or not
testing is in any pending legislation
this isn't always the case because
sometimes the legislation just says we
will be licensing
manufacturers testing labs etc but they
don't necessarily what they're going to
require from those laboratories
in order to get a license so the first
thing i'm going to look at is alabama
they are looking to legalize medical use
here in 2020.
there was a bill introduced in february
of this year so quite recently
and this bill would require a state-run
facility
to be licensed in order to perform
testing they don't talk about any
commercial testing they just mentioned
the need for a state-run facility
so arkansas they're looking towards full
legalization this year there's currently
two ballot initiatives in the works from
the presence of the state
one is going to be to expunge any past
criminal records and the second one
is going to be to allow recreational
adult use in the state
currently their program does require
testing to be done
on medical marijuana itself so
i would not be surprised at all if later
down the road testing was also required
for recreational use should it become
legalized later this year
so connecticut's another state that's
looking to fully legalize cannabis later
down the road
there was a bill introduced in the
spring of 2019 and that actually puts
the earliest legalization date of july
2022 if the bill as it stands does go
through
the legislator and governor have come
forth saying they are trying to propose
and prioritize recreational use this
year
and there's not currently any proposed
testing regulations in the bill
but we are seeing some laboratories pop
up in this state
so delaware is also looking to fully
legalize high thc
canvas this year they do not yet have
any licensing criteria proposed in the
bill going through the state legislator
but this is not uncommon and is actually
quite typical for this to come
after bill's approved or canvas is
legalized in some fashion
so i would not again be surprised based
on where delaware's going
that they would start to require testing
should full legalization
come about later this year florida is
continuing to
look to fully legalize high thc cannabis
this has been
a state that everyone's had an eye on
for a while and they are making headway
towards actually
fully legalizing recreational use later
this year
they currently actually have two bills
that are being proposed
one is looking to expunge criminal
records and one is looking to highly
legalize high thc cannabis completely so
that adults
over a certain age can and participate
recreationally
it's very safe to say that they would
continue to require testing to be done
by an iso iec
17825 accredited laboratory for
recreational use as well
just because that's what they're already
requiring for their medical
products and plan in the state
hawaii is also looking to fully legalize
cannabis
as well there was a bill introduced in
2019 but it didn't make it all the way
through the state's legislator last year
the governor has honestly come out and
said he is looking to prioritize
decriminalization of small quantities
first
and on based on what the bill looks like
now he'd actually be
proposing the smallest decriminalization
amount
prior to proposing full legalization he
has said people can have
up to one ounce for it to be
decriminalized so that is a very small
quantity when comparing it to other
states
so idaho is looking to legalize medical
use this year it is a current ballot
initiative
so residents are currently looking to
gather enough signatures to put it on
their 2020 ballot for later this year
as i mentioned previously they have not
even introduced or
thought about legalizing industrial hemp
in this state so it's obviously really
interesting
that they're looking to legalize
medicinally in this state when
hemp has been something that their
governor shied away from
however over half their population is in
favor of legalizing cannabis
for medicinal use so if they put it on
their ballot for 2020 it
was very likely that they would legalize
just based on voter support alone
kansas is looking to legalize high thc
cannabis for medical use
although the governor of the state
supports this he does not have support
in 2019
to move this initiative forward so he
put something for
the rest of the legislator did not agree
with him so
although it's not that likely candidates
would move forward in 2019 it's also not
unlikely because
a fair majority of the residents have
come forth saying that they do support
medical cannabis so
kentucky is another state that's looking
to legalize for medical purposes
a bill was introduced in 2019 but it did
not make it far enough through the
legislative report to become law
testing would be required in this state
which is also not too surprising as they
have a very large
hemp market and they currently require
testing to be done by third party
accredited laboratories as well
so montana is another state that's
looking to fully
legalize here later down the road in
2020 there's currently supporters
campaigning to get it on the 2020 ballot
and currently testing is required for
the medical market
in their state so again it would be fair
to assume that they will require testing
when the adult use market becomes open
and available in their state
mississippi so residents of the state
are currently looking to
obtain enough signatures and actually
just recently right before put this
presentation together got enough to put
that
on the 2020 ballot so this is one of
those states where
the people in the legislature do not
necessarily agree with their voters so
the legislature has not put forth
anything to actually legalize
medicinally and that's why
the state residents themselves got
together and rallied and got enough
signatures to put on the ballot
so if it went forth through that
obviously it could get legalized medical
use but the state
powers to be have said that they do not
approve of legalization in any fashion
as of now
so nebraska is putting legalization for
medical use on their ballot as well
there's no word yet on whether or not
testing would be required
but as an agricultural state we're
beginning to see hemp testing occur
more in it so it's not really surprising
for
me to assume that testing would also be
required for
medical use cannabis as well
new jersey is one of those states we've
really had high hopes for in the past
um we've been kind of looking at it for
a while here assuming they have a large
market and knowing that the legislature
and
people within the state really do want
to see it move forward to be fully
legalized in it
um it's more likely to pass this time
because it is on the 2020 ballot
and the majority of the residents in the
state do support full legalization
testing was in their previous
legislation they've put forth in
2019 and other years so again we can
definitely assume that testing would be
required in the state
if previous legislation goes through the
way it was already written
new mexico is aiming to fully legalize
adult use
thc cannabis market and their state
by this time this presentation airs
there are legislative sessions actually
to be over
so we would have more updates later down
in march
uh it is possible to get on the 2020
ballot through voter initiatives
such as presenting signatures to the
legislator but again
um we won't know more about that until
later in march when their legislative
session ends
new york is another state with a really
big population that we've been keeping
an eye on for a while
trying to see when they're going to pull
the trigger on fully legalizing
it's supported by the governor and
overwhelmingly supported by the
residents of the state
so it's really fair to say that it will
go over this year and they actually have
separate
hemp and cannabis medicinal use cannabis
programs for their state to be tested so
they have different requirements for
both
so it is really also fair to assume that
recreationally they would require
testing to be done as well
north carolina is looking to legalize
medicinally
it's a definitely an interesting
situation because
you cannot put something on the ballot
as a resident of the state through
obtaining signatures like some of the
other states that i was mentioning
so they can't put vendors on the ballot
however
there are some people in the legislature
in their state
that are in support of legalizing for
medical use especially now that they're
allowing cap cultivation in their state
uh it's not extremely likely that
they've legalized consistently this year
mainly because residents can't put it on
the ballot but it's not
outside the realm of possibility
north dakota is actually looking fully
legalized as well
they're a lot more open to this than
their neighbors to the south
so it is a current ballot initiative so
it is likely that it's going to be on
the ballot for 2020
so that people can vote to have full
legalization in the state which
the majority of their residents do
support
so currently third party testing by an
iso iec 1785 upgrade laboratory
is required so it would not be
surprising either if in this state
recreational use will lead to additional
testing laboratories
pennsylvania is also looking to fully
legalize high thc cannabis in 2020
it is supported by the governor and the
majority of the residents
but not by the house so the house has
come out and said that they would not
support a bill that was put forth by the
governor
so the governor actually did something
interesting here he went to
each county of the state and spoke in a
setting such as a town hall
just to talk to his residents and his
voters and his constituents to see how
they really felt about legalization
and he reported back that about 65 of
the population in the state
does approve of and want to see cannabis
be fully legalized in their state
so it would make sense that if it was
put on the ballot later down the road
that they would fully legalize testing
is already required in pennsylvania for
the medical
market so it would not again be
surprising if we saw this come forth
for the recreational market
rhode island is looking to legalize for
recreational use
so it is supported by their governor and
the majority of the residents but not by
the general assembly
um their governor is trying to move
forward and pick up the pace compared to
the rest of their new england neighbors
who have already fully legalized
cannabis
so they're attempting to gain some
traction now but
like i said the general support does not
support legalization
but in this state the voters do support
it
so south carolina is looking to legalize
for medical use they're looking to have
their own state-run medical cannabis
program
the bill is currently working its way
through the state legislator and they do
specifically call out the testing of the
plant and the products themselves
would be required
south dakota is actually looking to
potentially legalize the medical use
this year
it's on the ballot and the governor has
come out saying that she doesn't support
him cultivation they do not support
legalization of any kind here but a
small
majority of the voters in this state do
support legalization of medical cannabis
at this point in time
um so it will be on the ballot so we'll
see what happens but since the governor
and no one's put forth legislation we do
not know the if testing would be
required
lastly i just wanted to touch on
washington dc because there's legalized
use
in the jurisdiction there and the
borders of dc
but they're looking to tax and regulate
in-house so
the bill put forth would allow them to
tax and regulate their market
which would in turn require testing to
be done in dc itself
so overall we have 11 states moving
towards legalizing cannabis for medical
use and we have 10 states moving towards
legalizing cannabis for recreational use
six of the states that are looking to
have it legalized medically
would have testing required in their
legislation so we can see
a continuing trend of the majority of
states moving forth to legalize in some
fashion
are looking to also require testing to
ensure compliance and to ensure that the
consumers
know what's in the product that they're
purchasing
so we also have some states that are
looking to add testing requirements
later in 2020
so arizona is a state that hasn't been
requiring testing historically but they
are moving towards
actually requiring it for everything
that's going to be in the market
so as of november 1st 2020 all products
in the state of arizona will need to be
tested by an accredited laboratory
obama is another one of those states so
obviously they legalized medicine not
too terribly long ago uh and there are
testing labs there that are accredited
that are fully operational
but as of april 1st 2020 they will
actually be required to have everything
tested
whereas now it's more on a voluntary
basis and laboratories are up and ready
to go ready to take on what we're there
so more on the testing regulation side
so i think it's pretty cool how the
cannabis industry
has really responded to different issues
that have come up in different instances
we've seen a lot of states revising
their testing requirements in the past
couple of years
to require additional testing and a
response potentially to
something going on in the market or a
recall so it's been pretty interesting
compared to other
industries with testing legislators have
been really looking to
respond to public outcry in certain
situations
so for example you see maryland and
michigan among
several other states are requiring
vitamin e acetate testing
so although we could get into the topic
of vaping and by many acetate
i'll just leave it brief and say that
although most of it's coming
from black market products there are
some states that have issued recalls for
vitamin e acetate being
and the final product on the shelves of
dispensaries so we're seeing more states
in addition to michigan and maryland
also required by mini acetate testing
colorado has also been adding more
requirements they've added heavy metal
requirements pesticide requirements
in addition to many others and
california many of you guys are probably
familiar with but they expanded their
testing panel
of required tests three times in 2018
and another thing i'd like to touch on
is more states are also realizing the
importance of microbiological testing
just to make sure there's not certain
things present in the final product on
the shelves
that's been really important as well so
in my opinion compared to other
industries it's holly works with we've
definitely seen
people respond and add additional
testing when they feel like it's
necessary
and that can be a challenge for
laboratories but it's also
their way of ensuring that the public
feels like they can be more confident in
the final product that they're
purchasing
so i just want to touch really quick on
the usda's proposed testing requirements
i know most of you guys are probably
very aware of it so
i'm not going to necessarily go into a
ton of detail but i did want to touch on
a few things that they're proposing
as well as some of the comments that
we've seen that a lot of people
are working towards so currently
they strongly recommend iso iec 17025
accreditation by accreditation body
that's part of the ilac mra
so someone like an h2oi so they do say
strongly recommend they don't say
required as of yet
but based on how things are going which
i'll touch on my next slide it's likely
that that would be required
probably one of the hottest topics in
this hemp bill
is requiring de registration of testing
laboratories
so currently there's very few home
testing labs when you compare to the
rest of
the bonds in existence that are actually
registered with the dea currently as at
the time of this presentation it's 44
hemp testing laboratories
and when you compare all the other
laboratories that are up and running and
accredited
or not yet accredited and just getting
set up that's not a huge
portion of the labs in existence
um i've never personally worked with the
dea at hpla but i have some of my
customers who have and it sounds like
the process is quite
tedious and also at the same time
getting a drug enforcement agency
involved with testing a product that's
supposed to
now be federally legal a lot of
laboratories have seen that as something
that necessarily shouldn't be required
because that's still treating the plant
like it is
an irregular substance it also leaves
the legal limit of thc at 0.3
so we've seen some farmers somehow
growers
manufacturers in seats come forward and
say that
they want a little more leniency on this
point three percent that
no one seems to know where this point
three percent actually originated from
so that's another thing that they put
they put the heart and fast point three
there's some states that have left their
legal limit up a little bit higher and a
lot a little more leeway but that's
really rare and it's kind of unclear
if the usda is setting this at the 0.3
will actually
mean that other states have to often
completely fall within that
so the usda received almost 5 000
comments on their
regulation their interim rule perhaps uh
4
646 comments to be exact were received
by the usda
there are some trends that um holi and
our government relations team
noticed throughout these comments and i
did want to touch on some of this
so requiring iso iec 175 accreditation
instead of just strongly um recommending
it
is a comment that a lot of states a lot
of industry groups and a lot of testing
labs themselves actually put forward
it's an iso standard that's been around
for a really long time
decades and at this point it's used in a
lot of other industries as the standard
and the bar that is set for food
industry environmental industry
electrical industries mechanical
industries calibration testing
laboratories
so other industries do rely on this iso
standard
so it is something that a lot of people
even like some farm groups um
states themselves like i said are trying
to promote this because a lot of
laboratories in the state already doing
this
so i reinvent the wheel when the states
are already happy with what's going on
another thing is that
they're looking to require sampling by a
third party
so a lot of states
um have their own sampling requirements
for hemp
or for canvas right now where they
either require the testing laboratory to
do the sampling or they require the
grower themselves
to do the sampling obviously there's
some impartiality and some risk issues
when it comes to a grower manufacturer
sampling from their own product
so a lot of the comments that went
through are actually pushing for the
laboratory or a third party to do all
the sampling
just to ensure that there's no bias and
there's um impartiality when it comes to
the sampling
i think one of the biggest things that
it sounds like has been a trend
is not requiring dea registration for
some reasons i
previously touched on um having
laboratories jump through groups to work
with another federal agency is something
that people aren't really working
towards
and people even on the growers side
manufacturer side are worried
that having this step be done and then
meeting their product or their plant to
be tested it's going to create
a pretty big backlog when you look at
there's currently 44 dea labs and
knowing that they do have to jump
through some boots to get that
lastly like i mentioned before they want
the delta 9 th levels to be above the
0.3
if at all possible because the amount of
money lost
on a whole crop or a yield if the
percentage comes back from the testing
laboratories higher than that
can be extremely significant so people
are looking to have a little bit more
leeway
on that percentage it's unclear if they
will move forward with this
but that is another thing that we're
seeing trending in the comments
in terms of testing and the acceptable
legal limit there
so that's it for my presentation here's
my contact information if you guys
need it or have any questions for me i'd
be happy to
answer that and feel free to reach out
to me at any point in time
um again thank you so much for listening
to my presentation today and i look
forward to hearing from you if you have
any questions
thank you